DAVID TSENG: Hi everyone,
my name is David Tseng.
I am a software engineer
on the accessibility
team here at Google.
And I have here with me my
colleague, Volker Sorge, who
is a visiting professor from the
University of Birmingham.
We're here today to talk to you
about ChromeVox, and some
of the exciting work we've been
doing to make reading of
mathematics on the
web possible.
To tell you more about this,
I'm going to hand it off to
Volker for a brief introduction
to the work.
And I'll then come back for
a brief introduction to
ChromeVox, in general.
Volker.
VOLKER SORGE: Thank
you, David.
So my name is Volker Sorge.
I'm a senior lecturer
at the University of
Birmingham in the UK.
And I've been spending the last
year, together with the
ChromeVox team here, to make
an effort in order to make
scientific material that's out
of the web accessible for
people with visual
impairments.
And first, we have concentrated
on making
mathematics accessible,
using ChromeVox.
Now why is that important?
Well, one of the problems with
scientific material is that it
is a hurdle in education that
many people that have visual
independents are excluded from
having scientific material
readily available as their
normal peers would have.
Because it is much harder to
make scientific material fully
accessible.
And particularly, if you think
about something like
mathematics, it is not as
straightforward as reading
just regular texts.
Therefore, it is often very
difficult to make it
accessible using your average
screen reader.
Now there have been a number of
efforts in order to make,
in particular, mathematics
accessible,
that are on the web.
But these are generally efforts
that require either
particular, special tools or
particular plug-ins for
special browsers.
So what we have been trying to
do with ChromeVox is make
mathematics accessible in just
the standard screen reader--
so making, effectively,
mathematics a first class
citizen in the world
of accessibility.
And we have done, also, in
addition, some special
elements, like, in particular,
exploration of mathematics,
that we believe are fairly
novel, and that we're going to
demonstrate to you in
the upcoming hour.
So first, we'll start with a
general introduction to what
ChromeVox actually is, before we
then go into more detail on
how one can use it to speak
mathematics, and also, how one
can, in particular, use it to
customize how mathematics is
being spoke.
And for the general
introduction, that's going to
be done by David.
David, please.
DAVID TSENG: Thank
you, Volker.
So just to get everybody up to
speed and on the same page,
I'm going to give a demo of
ChromeVox, and its general
features and functionality as
a general screen reader.
So for the past, I'd say, three
or so years, we've been
developing ChromeVox.
And ChromeVox is just
a Chrome extension.
So it's all written
in JavaScript.
And we have access to all the
information that any other web
page would.
And this gives us a lot of
things that ordinary screen
readers don't get, and
everything that they do get.
So we've been able to create
something that, I think, is
fully featured, and allows
a blind user to
navigate all of the web.
So to start off with, I will
show everyone a standard page
from Wikipedia.
This is a square root.
The topic for this page
is on square roots.
And I will start off by simply
tabbing around, and letting
everyone hear the type of
feedback we provide.
CHROMEVOX: Navigation--
internal link.
This page has one alert.
Do you want Google Chrome
to save your password?
DAVID TSENG: So there, you've
heard quite a few things.
So it says a lot.
It says, first of all-- the
first thing that you've heard
was "navigation" and "link--"
"internal link." So those bits
of information are contextual.
And it tells you what the
currently focused item is.
So a user who's using a screen
reader can then know how to
interact with this.
So since it's a link, one can
press it, and therefore land
in another place on this page,
since it's an internal link.
And the second bit of feedback
you heard was an alert given
by the Chrome browser.
So we actually speak
that, as well.
So besides landing on focusable
items, we can
actually move about the
page and move to
things that aren't focusable.
So you do that by pressing the
ChromeVox modifiers, and the
arrow keys.
So let's hear what
that sounds like.
CHROMEVOX: Comma.
Search--
internal link.
Quote square roots quote
redirects here.
For the music festival,
see square roots--
link.
DAVID TSENG: And you
hear quite a few
other things there.
There were some static
pieces of text.
There were some more links.
And one other item that is kind
of interesting to point
out is-- you heard a sound
effect, kind of
like a "ding" sound.
And that actually represents
a link.
So whatever a user hears that,
they automatically know that
they can click on it.
So some other interesting things
are that a user doesn't
necessarily have to
go item by item.
They can actually jump from
section to section.
And that's done via another
keyboard command.
And let's hear what
that sounds like.
CHROMEVOX: Contents--
heading two.
DAVID TSENG: So there, I just
skipped a lot of material on
the page, and was able to jump
right to the contents listing.
So let's try that again, and see
if we find anything else
interesting.
CHROMEVOX: Properties--
heading two.
DAVID TSENG: All right,
and keep on going.
CHROMEVOX: Left bracket,
edit source-- link--
pipe, edit, beta,
right bracket--
link.
Enlarge the graph of the
function f left parenthesis x
right parenthesis equals square
root of x-- math.
DAVID TSENG: And there, we have
something that alludes to
the rest of the talk.
And it's how we actually make
it possible to read that
expression, and make it possible
for ChromeVox, and
the user, to then communicate,
using something that's a
little bit richer and a little
bit more unique.
So with that, one last thing
to show is we can actually
read content, continuously,
just by
pressing another command.
And it'll actually read it kind
of like a book, from this
point on to whenever you
want to stop it.
CHROMEVOX: Made up of
half a parabola--
link-- with a vertical
directrix--
link-- dot.
The principal square root
function f left parenthesis x
right parenthesis equals square
root of x-- math--
usually just referred to as the
quote square root function
quote, is a function.
DAVID TSENG: And I'll
just stop it there.
And that, overall, gives you a
flavor of what ChromeVox is,
and what it does, and how the
user would use it, and a
little bit of a taste of how
math works, and spoken math
sounds like.
So with that, I will throw
it back to Volker.
And he will continue on with
some of the more interesting
things that we're doing
with math, and
how this is all possible.
VOLKER SORGE: Thank
you, David.
So as you could already hear
when David was demonstration
the continuous reader on the
previous paragraph, there was
math contained in
the paragraph.
And the math was just being
spoken out in a
fairly verbose way.
We'll talk about that a bit
later, why this is so verbose.
And in order to explain how that
is being spoken out, it
is probably worthwhile going a
bit into detail on how math is
actually represented
on the web.
And in particular, for those
who are not fully aware how
math on webpages works, or
should work, I'll give a quick
introduction on that now.
So ideally, mathematics on the
web is represented by a
special markup language
called MathML.
MathML has been around
for some time.
And it has evolved and matured
to a degree that it's now been
made a stand for HTML5,
and as a consequence,
also for EPUB 3.
So in other words, every EPUB
3 reader, in the future,
should also be able to
deal with MathML.
Now the question, of course,
arises, why is there a
specialist markup language
just for mathematics.
Well, the reason is that
mathematics is fairly
involved, in terms of the way
expressions are being set up
and how they're being
structured, which is normally
not doable--
or not easily doable--
with just regular HTML.
In particular, think about that
regular HTML is very good
with dealing with text
and these things.
It can also do sub
and superscript.
However as soon as things become
more involved, as in a
mathematics expression--
which is, by nature, effectively
two dimensional
and very, very nested--
HTML alone can normally
not deal with it.
Therefore, MathML provides all
the basic functionality--
or the basic tags--
in order to create complex
mathematics expressions, and
display them on the web.
Now while it is, in general,
a good thing that MathML is
fairly mature, and that it's a
part of standards, what is a
drawback about MathML is that
it is not implemented in all
browsers, or all
EPUB 3 readers.
As a consequence, there are
several ways of getting
mathematics on the web
to work nevertheless.
So one of the ways it is done
by many sites, such as
Wikipedia, by default, as well
as other pages, is that one
actually displays an image of
the mathematics instead of
having a MathML expression
in there.
And therefore, it can be easily
read by people who can
actually see the image.
But it cannot necessarily be
picked up by a screen reader.
Now the advantage of this is,
sometimes, that the real
mathematics is still provided
somewhere in the background,
not visible.
And therefore, it can indeed
be used by screen reader.
And I'll demonstrate it to you
later, how that is being done.
The other way of displaying
mathematics on all browsers on
all platforms is by using a
little library called MathJax,
which is done by the
MathJax Consortium.
And if you want to check this
out, this is at mathjax.org.
And the way this works is that
MathJax can be injected in any
page that contents
mathematics.
And it's JavaScript.
And it just renders the
mathematics, which is either
given as MathML or a more
traditional markup language
like LaTeX or ASCIIMath.
And it then renders
the mathematics.
Now the challenge with this
process, for a screen reader
who actually wants to use the
mathematics in order to speak
it, is that we actually have to
deal with all these types
of mathematics as
they can occur.
So we have to be able to deal
with just standard MathML
expressions as well as
expressions rendered by
MathJax, or expressions that are
just hidden somewhere, in
an alternative text,
behind the image.
And I'll show you,
now, how that
actually works, in practice.
Right, so let me just quickly
demonstrate how this is then
spoken by ChromeVox.
So let's go to the first
math expression,
again, in this paragraph.
CHROMEVOX: f left parenthesis
x right parenthesis equals
square root of x--
math.
VOLKER SORGE: As you can see,
the first maths expression
here, in the DOM, is actually
the math expression which is
in the caption of this
particular image.
But it still spoke it.
And it went to it.
And you can see it's been
indicated by this highlighter,
which is, for instance,
particularly helpful if you
need to see where you are in the
text-- so for instance, if
you are dyslexic.
And for dyslexic students,
this is useful.
And we'll just go to the next
maths expression, which should
now be this one in
the paragraph.
CHROMEVOX: --left parenthesis
x right parenthesis equals
square root of x-- math.
VOLKER SORGE: Right.
Now as I said, this works,
now, nicely.
Because I'm actually logged
into Wikipedia.
And if I were to now log out of
the Wikipedia page, I then
would get it just as an image.
And it would still work.
Because we can use the
alternative text, which is in
the background, which is
actually the LaTeX expression
which you saw of the
beginning before
the MathJax was rendering.
Now I'm not going to log out
of this Wikipedia page,
because we will need it later.
However, let's go to a different
page, where we have
a similar effect.
CHROMEVOX: Sum from
Wolfram Math.
VOLKER SORGE: And this is
Mathworld, which is a
particular encyclopedia,
just for mathematics.
And what happens there is that
you have the mathematics given
as an image only, always.
However, you also have
alternative text.
And in that case,
it's ASCIIMath.
And we can leverage this
ASCIIMath in order to
pronounce it.
And just to show you that the
math expressions here are
indeed images, I'll just
grab it quickly, and
I'll move them around.
See, this is an image.
And I can take this sum, and
just move it around on the
screen here.
And all these are images.
CHROMEVOX: A sum is the
result of an addition.
For example, adding 1, 2, 3,
and 4 gives the sum 10,
written 1 plus 2 plus
3 plus 4 equals 10.
Full stop.
Math.
VOLKER SORGE: So you could
hear, now, that this is,
indeed, a math expression.
Although it was an image, it's
being fully pronounced because
we can leverage the
alternative text.
And you could hear, also, why
it was a math expression,
because it was specially
announced using an earcon as
well as, in the end, an
announcement that this is a
math expression.
Similarly, we can go to the
next math expression, for
instance, and--
CHROMEVOX: k equals 1 under and
4 over n-ary summation.
k equals 10-- full
stop-- math.
VOLKER SORGE: So again, this
is the maths expression how
it's being spoken
at the moment.
And this now gives us the
possibility to have math
spoken where it's on Wikipedia,
even without
logging in, as well as on
MathWorld, as well as on many
other sites where there's
a similar effect.
So for instance, there's many
math blocks out there.
So one of the block so I'm going
to demonstrate here is a
famous block from a famous
mathematician, Terry Tao, who
is a Fields medalist winner.
And he regularly blogs on his
latest mathematical research.
And he does it in a similar vein
to what we've just seen
on the MathWorld site, that the
mathematics is actually
given in images.
And I'll grab one of those
images here, and move it
around, so you can see that
this is an image.
So this is an image.
Here's another one.
But the alternative text in the
background is indeed LaTeX.
And therefore, we can actually
speak it, using ChromeVox.
So let's just speak this first
definition, for instance.
CHROMEVOX: Definition one--
multiple dense divisibility--
let y greater than or
equal to 1-- math.
For each natural number k
greater than or equal to 0--
math--
we define a notion of k--
tuply y--
math--
dense divisibility recursively,
as follows--
list with two items--
every natural number-- list
item-- n-- math--
is 0--
math--
tuply y--
densely divisible.
If-- list item--
k greater than or equal
to 1-- math-- and--
VOLKER SORGE: Right,
I'll stop it here.
So what you could hear was
that all the math in the
paragraph has been spoken.
Although it's as images, we used
the alternative texts in
order to translate it with
the MathJax library.
It's the same library we saw,
previously, rendering the math
on the Wikipedia page.
When it comes back from the
MathJax rendering, we can then
use this representation
in order to speak it.
And however we do this in the
background, in that sense,
none of the content
in the page is
actually, physically changed.
So it still has the same visual
appearance as before.
What you could also hear, when
we were speaking the maths, is
that it was always giving a
little earcon, and the math
announcement, which gives you
the possibility to actually
find out where the math is.
And this is, in particular,
important if you want to have
more interaction
with the math.
And with this, I'll pass back
to David, who's now going to
explain to you one of the
specialities of ChromeVox
which allows you to actually
interactively explore a
mathematics expression, which we
believe is a very important
step in order for people to
fully engage with mathematical
content that's on the web.
DAVID TSENG: I think everybody
can identify with me,
personally, in that hearing all
of this is kind of a lot
to take in.
I mean, if you consider the
often quoted figure of 7 plus
or minus 2 bits of information
that we, as humans, can store
and keep in our short term
memory, what we just heard was
way more than seven words.
So what do we do about that?
Well, speaking personally, I, in
the days when I was in high
school and in university, used
several methods to actually
access mathematics.
One primary way, and one that's
pretty popular still,
is to use audio books.
And at the time, we actually
used these four-track audio
tapes-- so a tape which has two
sides, using both stereo
channels, splitting those into
mono, and having each channel
record audio tracks.
And someone--
a really, really nice
volunteer--
would sit down in a room
and read through
an entire math textbook.
So this included anything from
algebra all the way up to
calculus and even beyond.
I remember listening to a real
analysis book in college,
which was once in a lifetime
experience.
So it was really, really
difficult.
And there was a lot of
rewinding, and pausing, and
taking notes.
So we feel like ChromeVox can do
a lot better, since we have
a computer, and we have the
ability to write code to make
things easier.
So what have we done, exactly?
Well, think about
any expression--
and I'll demo this,
briefly, later on.
But just think about something
that you've seen in the past,
say, the quadratic formula.
How would you actually
read that?
It's not exactly obvious.
And even harder is then to tell
a person who's never seen
it before where all
the pieces lie.
So if you think of it
like geography--
where are all the countries?
And where are all the
large pieces?
Where are all the continents?
And if you want to dive in to
a specific region, well,
what's inside there?
And how do you actually give
a quick summary of
all of these things?
And how do you actually let
a person then ask you to
describe something further?
So this is the challenge that
ChromeVox has faced.
And we feel like we've come up
with a pretty good solution.
So let me go ahead and just
demo that for you now.
We can hear how does it now.
And I can show you how a person
would actually explore
the various pieces of it.
CHROMEVOX: We have x equals
minus b plus/minus square root
of b square minus 4ac
divided by 2a--
math.
DAVID TSENG: Now you
see immediately
notice quite a few things.
There were a lot of words,
for one thing.
We also slowed down the speech
rate quite a bit so that we
can do some more intelligent
things like speeding up
certain parts, slowing down
others, inserting pauses,
changing pitch.
So one thing to add there is,
you'll notice a little bit of
pitch drift.
So all the stuff in the
numerator, you'll hear go up a
little bit.
All the stuff in the
denominator, you'll hear go
down a little bit.
In that power, the b squared,
the squared part is actually
up a little bit, even
more, in pitch.
So it gives you another
dimension to work with.
So pitch gives me, as someone
who is the listener, an
additional hint as to how high
something, or low something,
is vertically represented.
But this is still a pretty
beefy example.
If you remember your first
algebra class, it's a lot to
take in for someone
who is seeing this
for the first time.
So how do we actually let
someone explore it?
Well, we have one of these other
ChromeVox commands that
lets you go and dive deeper
into the structure.
So I'll go ahead and hit that.
CHROMEVOX: Entered math--
x equals minus b plus--
DAVID TSENG: And you
heard that again.
There was a sound icon that
represents exploring something.
And you heard the expression
starting to read again.
And I just stopped it, for
the sake of brevity.
So how do we actually
go and figure out
what pieces are here?
What's the general geography?
So there is this concept of
granularities, in ChromeVox,
that lets you zoom in and zoom
out, essentially, of something
on the page.
So I'll go ahead
and press that.
And let's hear how
that sounds.
CHROMEVOX: Down to
level one-- x--
DAVID TSENG: So I just
moved down a level.
And I'm in a bigger chunk
not as big as the whole
expression.
So what is this?
This is x.
And it's obviously very
important, so we let the user
hear that in isolation.
And we have some keys
to move you around.
And those are basically to move
you forward and backward
on the current level
of things.
So let's hear what
that sounds like.
And I will move forward.
CHROMEVOX: --equals--
DAVID TSENG: So "equals" is
obviously also very important
in this equation.
So what's the next thing?
And I will go ahead and
press Next again.
CHROMEVOX: --minus b plus/minus
square root of b
square minus 4ac
divided by 2a.
DAVID TSENG: And you
heard, again,
that whole, big fraction.
And you heard the pitch changes,
and everything else.
And I will press the
Next key again.
CHROMEVOX: Minus b
DAVID TSENG: Oup, and you heard
a little "ch-ch" sound.
And that represents that we've
bumped against an edge.
So there's only three big
chunks in this thing.
And as a user that, perhaps,
has never seen this formula
before, well, I now have a
really good sense of all the
big pieces, and all the
big players, here.
But say I, still, am a little
bit hazy on this fraction, and
I want to look a little
bit more.
I can actually dive
in even deeper.
So let's do that, and hear
how that sounds.
CHROMEVOX: Down to level 2--
minus b plus/minus square root
of b square minus 4ac
DAVID TSENG: And you heard
the numerator.
So that sounds great.
And let's move forward.
CHROMEVOX: 2a
DAVID TSENG: And that's
the denominator.
So that all makes
a lot of sense.
And let's try moving
forward again.
CHROMEVOX: 2a
DAVID TSENG: Oup, bounced
against an edge.
Move back.
CHROMEVOX: Minus b plus
DAVID TSENG: OK.
We heard that before.
Move back again.
CHROMEVOX: Minus b
DAVID TSENG: Oup, another edge.
All right.
So we've gotten a really
clear sense of where
everything is, again.
So I can even dive
even further.
And let's do that, real quick,
into this numerator.
CHROMEVOX: Down to level 3--
minus
DAVID TSENG: OK.
Minus
CHROMEVOX: Minus
DAVID TSENG: Oup, that's
the beginning.
So let's move forward,
instead of backward.
CHROMEVOX: B plus/minus
DAVID TSENG: Forward
CHROMEVOX: Square root of
b square minus 4ac.
Square root of--
DAVID TSENG: --oup,
and that's the end
CHROMEVOX: --b square
minus 4ac.
DAVID TSENG: And if we really
wanted to, we can even dive
into the square root.
So let's do that.
CHROMEVOX: Down to level
4-- b minus 4ac.
DAVID TSENG: And that's it.
So with that, it is our hope
that students will be able to
then really easily explore
an equation like this.
That's now becoming
possible with what
we're doing with ChromeVox.
And in the past, you would have
had to rewind and fast
forward through a tape, and do
it that way, or perhaps, if
you're really lucky, get
math through braille.
But with the possibility of
using online math, now you can
get it in real time, and
look up a wealth of
information on the web.
So with that, I'll pass back
to Volker, who will discuss
some of the intricacies of
actually applying some of
these text to speech changes,
and the way we speak, and some
cool stuff that you, as a
developer, can actually do to
improve any math that you
might come across.
VOLKER SORGE: And this, as you
have previously mentioned
earlier, at the moment, what
we've demonstrated to you, the
way things were spoken, is
very, very verbose in the
sense that every single
element is indeed
being spoken out.
Now that is not necessarily
how mathematics is being
spoken in real life.
All right.
Often, you omit things, although
they are written.
And this is something we can--
I'm going to demonstrate a few
examples where things are
being very awkward when
everything is being spoken,
and where we then apply changes
to our underlying
structure and rule base in order
to have them spoken more
intelligently.
And I will then, afterwards,
tell you how this is actually
being done, and how that can
be customized by users,
themselves, or by creators
of web pages.
Right.
So this is, here, a Wikipedia
page with a matrix example.
So matrixes are particularly
difficult to speak, because
they are fully two dimensional
objects.
And I'll show you, at first,
how we could speak it in a
full, verbose fashion.
CHROMEVOX: Left square
bracket matrix--
element one, one--
1.
Element two, one--
9.
Element three, one--
minus 13.
Element one, two--
20.
Element two, two--
5.
Element three, two--
minus 6.
Right square bracket--
full stop--
math.
VOLKER SORGE: Right, so as you
could hear, everything was
being spoken.
Every bracket, every punctuation
is being spoken.
Now we have the possibility,
in ChromeVox, to actually
change the underlying
representation in a way that
we can get a bit more
intelligence, a bit more
semantics in there,
if you like.
And actually, I'll do that now,
in order so you can see
how this is being spoken then.
CHROMEVOX: Matrix--
row one, column one--
1.
Column two--
9.
Column three--
negative 13.
Row two, column one--
20.
Column two--
5.
Column three--
negative 6.
Math.
VOLKER SORGE: Right, so as you
can see here, ChromeVox is
slightly more intelligent.
It applies a slightly
better way of
pronouncing rows and columns.
In particular, it omits some
of the punctuation which is
not strictly necessary for a
reader to know, exactly.
Whether this is a round bracket
or a square bracket,
in this particular instance,
might not make any big
difference.
Right.
These things can get
particularly worse when the
underlying representation is
very similar, however the
meaning is particularly
different.
So let's go back to our
square root example.
And I'll read you the first
example here, in the normal,
verbose style.
Let's go to this case
statement down
here, on the page.
CHROMEVOX: Square root
of x square equals--
vertical line--
x--
equals--
left curly bracket, matrix
element one, one--
x comma--
element two, one--
if x greater than
or equal to 0--
element one, two--
minus x comma--
element two, two--
if x less than 0.
Full stop-- math.
VOLKER SORGE: So what you could
hear, now, was that it
not only spoke everything in a
very verbose way-- all the
vertical bars, as well as
the opening brace--
but ChromeVox also fell into the
trap that it saw something
it thought might look
like it's a matrix.
Because it's exactly the same
MathML structure, underneath,
as the matrix on the previous
page, which I have
demonstrated.
Now if we apply some slightly
more intelligent way of
reading this here, we actually
get something
slightly more sensible.
CHROMEVOX: Equation sequence--
square root of x square equal
absolute value of x equal--
case statement, case one-- x, if
x greater than or equal to
0-- case two--
negative x, if x less than 0.
Full stop-- math.
VOLKER SORGE: So you could see
here that what happened was
that now, first of all,
ChromeVox has a more semantic
interpretation of
the expression.
It gives you a quick summary
at the beginning-- it's a
sequence of equations.
So there's more than two
parts of the equation.
And then, it reads it in a
more intelligent way, by
realizing something is an
absolute value, as well as
actually finding the case
statement correctly, rather
than pronouncing it as a matrix,
as it has done before.
And a similar semantic
interpretation can then be
applied to all the
other statements.
So if you go back, for instance,
to this statement
here, and pronounce it, first,
in the old way--
CHROMEVOX: f left parenthesis
x right parenthesis equals
square root of x-- math.
VOLKER SORGE: All right,
supply some semantics.
CHROMEVOX: f of x equals square
root of x-- math.
VOLKER SORGE: Right.
So as you could see here,
instead of pronouncing all the
parentheses, we now say "f of
x." Because we realize this
is, indeed, a function
application, and we pronounce
it accordingly.
Now the way this is being done
is by using an underlying
speech rule engine, which allows
for various ways of
customizing the rule base that
is being used in order to
speak the mathematical
expressions.
And I'll explain, very briefly,
how that works.
Effectively, what happens is
the math expression is, of
course, a tree representation.
In particular, it's a MathML
tree representation.
And this representation is
recursively being traversed.
And in every node,
an applicable
rule is being computed.
And that rule then has some
actions which fire, in the
sense that they produce some
speech output, as well as
produce a way to further
recursively traverse the rest
of the tree.
And these rules can be
customized in various ways.
One way of customizing them is
customizing them with respect
to mathematical domain.
So what might be useful in one
mathematical domain might not
be the same in another
mathematical domain.
And when I say "mathematical
domain," what I actually mean
is something like algebra,
geometry, analysis, calculus,
things like this.
So you might want to pronounce
one expression, in algebra,
differently than in geometry.
In addition to this, we have
the possibilities of
customizing rules
by their style.
And when I say "style" here, I
mean something like, do I want
it to be spoken short.
Do I want it to be spoken in a
verbose mode, for instance.
Do I want it to be spoken in
some particular way that I
like, and nobody else
likes, et cetera.
And finally, we also have the
possibility of swapping the
underlying representation
while the
speech engine is active.
So that's what I've
just showed you.
The underlying MathML
representation, here, was
swapped out with a more
semantic enriched
representation.
Now the problem with this
semantic enrichment is, of
course, that this is a fairly
ad hoc procedure.
MathML is a language which
primarily aims for display.
So there's two types
of MathML.
One is called Presentation
MathML, and one is called
Content MathML.
The idea of Presentation MathML
is that it takes care
of how the math expression is
being laid out on the page.
And this is what we're currently
working with.
The idea of Content MathML is
that an author of a math
expression actually puts
in some semantics.
Unfortunately, that is hardly
available on the web.
Therefore, what we have to
do is we have to take the
Presentation MathML expression,
and interpret it
in a way that seems
reasonable to us.
Obviously, this can break
down in many cases.
And therefore, the person who
actually knows best how to
interpret a MathML expression is
generally the author of the
expression, themselves.
As a consequence, we believe
that it is very useful for
people to actually be able to
customize the speech rules in
a way that they will pronounced
the MathML
expressions they write
in the correct way.
We therefore, in ChromeVox,
offer an API to users out
there, to authors of web pages,
to developers of EPUB 3
readers that allows them to
define their own math rules--
either override or add
to our rule base--
in order to have math
expressions being spoken in
the way they prefer.
And the rest of the time I will
now spend introducing
this particular way of--
these particular rules, as well
as demonstrate how they
can be written, and what the
different components
of these rules are.
Let's, for this purpose, all
go back to our favorite
example, the quadratic
formula.
We'll start manipulating the
division in the formula in
order to demonstrate how
we can change rules.
Right.
Here, I'll bring up the
console quickly.
Let me get back to
the expression.
CHROMEVOX: Given we have x
equals minus b plus/minus
square root of b square minus
4ac divided by 2a--
math.
VOLKER SORGE: Right, so this is
the default way, currently,
ChromeVox speaks
the expression.
I will now write a rule
here, in the console.
I've already written it
previously, so I'll just bring
it up here, and explain to you
the components that will alter
to the way the expression
is being spoken.
Right.
So what you can see here, in
detail, is that we have--
these function names are the way
one can call ControlVox--
sorry, not ControlVox,
ChromeVox--
through the API.
So here's the ChromeVox API.
It's, in particular,
the math API.
And it offers a defined
rule function.
And the function here, at the
moment, has four components.
All of these are string
components.
The first component is a name.
It's practically irrelevant
what that name is.
The whole idea of a name is that
one can more easily find
the rule later, somewhere in the
speech rule engine, say,
for debugging purposes.
But for now, we can
just ignore this.
So we'll just call this
"fraction rule."
Then, comes some admin
information which has to do
with the domain, and the style,
I've been referring to
previously.
So the domain was, just to
recall this, the idea that we
can specialize our rules with
respect to different
mathematical domains such as
algebra, geometry, et cetera.
In addition, we always have a
default domain, which is the
one we're working on right now,
which means that if, for
a particular domain, no rule is
there, we can always fall
back to the default rule.
And currently, the way domains
are being selected is
interactively, by the user.
Right.
So this is what the default,
here, says.
Then, we have a little dot,
which separates the domain
name from the style name.
And styles--
again, we have styles like
short, verbose, or I think we
also have super brief.
But there is no limit to what
you want to call your style.
If you want to call your style
after your personal name, then
we'll have an additional style
in ChromeVox, in the future.
And again, there is
a default style.
Here, we're working, now, on
the default domain, and the
style is short.
All right.
And then, the rest of the rule
is effectively a way how to
test whether a rule is
applicable, plus the action
the rule is supposed
to perform.
In ChromeVox, this is given
the other way around.
We first start with the action
and then with the
precondition, or the part of
the rule that tests whether
the actual rule is applicable.
I'll tell you, in a second,
why this is the case.
Let's first have a look at this
letter part, which talks
about the precondition if
the rule is applicable.
What we want is a node, which
is our fraction up here.
This division node is given
by a MathML tag,
which is called mfrac.
And we select this using an
XPath expression here.
So this is a regular XPath
expression, which just says,
well, the current node--
the node we are on--
is a node with an mfrac tag
in the MathML name space.
So this is just a regular
XPath expression.
Then, the rule will fire.
And it will perform
it's action.
So what are the Actions?
Well, actions are a sequence
of components of different
things the rule does.
In this case, we only have
one compartment.
And that component is currently
composed of two things--
the type of the component,
as well as
what is being performed.
So the type of the
component here is
given in square brackets.
In this case, the type is t,
which means it's just a text
that is being spoken.
And the text that is being
spoken is then given as a
string here, in string syntax,
with double quotes at the
beginning and the end.
So when we find the division
node, all we want, at this
point, is a string being spoken
where it says, "some
division." Let's put
that rule in.
And let's see what ChromeVox
says now.
CHROMEVOX: Given we have x
equals some division-- math.
VOLKER SORGE: Right.
That's all it says--
some division.
x equals some division.
We haven't specified
anything else.
In particular, what we have not
specified here is how it
should deal with any of the
other content that's still in
the expression.
So all we say at this
point is, say one
string and then stop.
Do not recurse any further.
I'll show you, in a second, how
we can do that, otherwise.
Let's first talk a bit more
about the precondition.
So the precondition here is an
XPath expression, as I said,
that selects this particular
node--
this particular node
with the mfrac tag.
So it's this division node.
Now in addition to this, one
can then give additional
constraints.
And the number of additional
constraints is unlimited.
Therefore, this is the reason
why we put the precondition at
the end of this particular
rule definition.
Because you can add more, and
more, and more, and more
constraints to it.
And I'll add one constraint,
just for you to be able to see
what this will look like.
So when we say, OK, so we want
this rule just to be
applicable to something
that says that
it's the node, itself.
And it has a descendant, which
is an m square root.
All right?
So that means it has a
descendant, which is a square
root, up there.
And again, this is in the
MathML name space.
Right, sorry.
Unexpected token means I have
forgotten to close my
expression, my string
expression,
with a square root.
Let's see whether
it's applicable.
Well, the thing is that we
haven't really changed any of
the actions.
So let's change the actions,
so we can actually hear
whether the different rule
is being applied.
"--some division with
square root."
CHROMEVOX: Given we have x
equals some division with
square root-- math.
VOLKER SORGE: Right.
So this has, indeed, worked.
And it now applies
the other rule.
So we have specialized the
rule even further.
So in addition, we can now add
more and more constraints.
Anything XPath1 allows you to
express, you can express in
these constraints.
And those are binary
constraints.
So they only have
to hold, or not.
Right.
So this is as far as I want to
explain the preconditions.
Now let's examine, a bit
further, what we can do in
terms of the actions
of our rule.
In particular, just having one
string pronounced, if you
actually have a complex
expression, is usually not
very fruitful.
So we might want to have
a bit more pronounced.
Therefore, let's dive into the
expression and pronounce some
of the child nodes, actually.
Right.
So we now start a
new component.
Components are being separated
by semicolons, so that's very
similar to what you have
in regular JavaScript.
And we now want to specify
a new component.
And this is a particular
component which works on
single nodes.
So therefore, it gets
the type n.
Again, the type is given
in square brackets.
And now we can write a selector
which is just yet
another XPath expression.
So we write another XPath
selector that selects whatever
child we want to work on,
or whatever node we
want to work on.
It doesn't necessarily
have to be a child.
You can effectively also work
on any other node that is
reachable from this particular
node you're on.
But in our case, we want
to work on the child.
But let's not work on both.
Let's just work on the second
on, for instance.
So this XPath expression, now,
just selects, from the given
node, the second child node.
Right.
And what the action now does
is it will pronounce the
string "some division with
square root." And afterwards,
it will ask the speech rule
engine to recurse on this node
that we have selected here.
Let's do that again.
CHROMEVOX: Given we have x
equals some division with
square root 2a--
math.
VOLKER SORGE: Right.
So what you can hear is that we
heard the expression up to
the division.
Then, it would pronounced
the string.
And then, it would pronounce
the second child node.
Right.
Similarly, we could now
put in more content.
So say we put in another
string of type t.
Say this is now a string
called a numerator.
And we now, for instance,
want to recurse on the
first node, as well--
on the first child as well,
not the first node.
Let's do that.
Let's listen to what's
happening.
CHROMEVOX: Given we have x
equals some division with
square root 2a and
numerator minus b
plus/minus square root--
VOLKER SORGE: I'll
stop it here.
We all know what the
numerator is.
But you can see how
this now works.
Now one of the things that David
pointed out earlier was
that you can actually do changes
to the way the text to
speech engine speaks things
from within a rule.
And let's do that.
The way this works is by
adding, in particular,
annotations to each component.
So for instance, say we want
to change the pitch on the
first component that's
being spoken.
Or in our case here, it's the
second component of the
denominator.
And let's say we just want to
have a significantly pitch
change, say, to 1.5.
Let's see how that sounds.
CHROMEVOX: Given we have x
equals some division with
square root 2a and numerator
minus b plus--
VOLKER SORGE: So you could
hear that the pitch was
changed quite drastically when
the denominator of the
division was being pronounced.
So the way we do these
annotations is by adding in
round brackets, the particular
property we want to change, as
well as the value
that changes it.
All right.
So in addition, we can, for
instance, also increase the
rate of the speech.
Say we increase it to 2.5.
And now let's see what's
being spoken now.
CHROMEVOX: Given we have x
equals some division with
square root 2a and
numerator minus--
VOLKER SORGE: That
was not really--
That was--
CHROMEVOX: Simple school
algebra, Volker Sorge, the
third April, 2013
VOLKER SORGE: Sorry, that was
not much of a change.
I'll just refresh the console
so we can see a bit more.
Let's try to change it to
something different.
Maybe 0.5 will make
a difference.
CHROMEVOX: Given we have x
equals some division with
square root 2a and
numerator minus--
VOLKER SORGE: Now you could
hear that it was actually
quite a bit faster.
So what else can we
do with this?
Well, another thing that we've
heard earlier was that we can
add pauses to our rule.
Let's do that as well.
Let's add a pause annotation,
say, to the second--
uh, no, to the first
of these--
children that we speak.
And let's add quite
a drastic pause.
Pauses are given in
milliseconds.
So let's add one second,
so we can actually
hear it more clearly--
so 1,000.
CHROMEVOX: Given we have x
equals some division with
square root 2a and numerator
minus b--
VOLKER SORGE: Right.
So the effect you could hear
here was something I wanted to
demonstrate.
It is that the pause, as well as
all the other annotations--
i.e. the pitch and the rate--
than we give a particular node
here, or particular component,
are recursively being applied
by the speech rule engine.
That means if we change the
pitch somewhere, this pitch
change will be propagated
further down in the recursive
traversal of the tree.
That means is we have nested
expressions, and we change the
pitch several times, these
changes will add up, which
gives a very nice effect
when it comes to
pitch and rate changes.
It doesn't really give a very
nice effect when it comes to
pause changes.
Because what that means is
that the pause is applied
after every single element
that occurs.
So you might want that.
But you don't necessarily
want that.
So in this particular
case, we don't.
So how do we actually do it in
order to apply the pause
between two chunks, rather
than having it applied
recursively, during traversing
the tree?
The way this works-- and I'll
show it to you here--
is by adding the pause
explicitly as we recall a
personality annotation,
which is another
component of the actions.
And this component
has the type p.
So we put that in here.
Let's get the bracketing
right.
And let's see what
happens now.
CHROMEVOX: Given we have x
equals some division with
square root 2a and numerator
minus b--
VOLKER SORGE: Right.
What you could hear now was that
the pause was actually
only applied straight after
the denominator had been
pronounced.
Right.
And in addition to this, we can
also, for instance, change
the volume.
But I'm not going
to demonstrate
that now, in detail.
Instead, I'm going to
demonstrate one final thing we
can do with these speech rules,
and also, one final
component--
one type of component--
for the action.
And that is useful when you have
a node where you do not
necessarily know how many
children the node has, and you
want to recurse over
all these nodes.
And we'll do that--
give them our division here.
Right.
And this component is
of type m, which
just stands for multinode.
And you then give it
a set of nodes.
In our case, we select the set
of nodes, again, with an XPath
expression, which is
just all subnodes--
or all child nodes-- of
our mfrac expression.
Let's do that.
Let's see what happens.
CHROMEVOX: Given we have x
equals some division with
square root minus b plus/minus
square root of b
square minus 4ac 2a--
math.
VOLKER SORGE: Right.
So what you could hear now was
that all the elements are
actually being pronounced
properly this time, in order,
because this is just the regular
order within the
MathML expression.
Now obviously, for an expression
like division,
where you really know that you
only have two children, this
might not make a lot of sense.
But if you do not know exactly
how many children there are--
say, in the matrix expression
we've demonstrated earlier--
you have to use this way off
accessing the children.
And then you have, in addition,
the opportunity, or
the possibility, to put in
something that is being spoken
in between all of these
expressions.
And the last thing I'll
demonstrate to you now is
giving what we call a separator
string as a further
annotation to our component.
And the separator is just a
regular string, in this case.
And let's just say, "divided
by," and spell it right, and
see what happens now.
CHROMEVOX: Given we have x
equals some division with
square root minus b plus/minus
square root of b square minus
4ac divided by 2a--
math.
VOLKER SORGE: Right.
Back, we are, at the original
expression.
Right.
So this, so far, is the
explanation of this API.
And why did we go into that
much detail in order to
demonstrate to you how
this API works?
Well, the basic idea of
ChromeVox is, since it is an
open project, that we're
hoping that people will
exploit this API in the future
in order to write explicit
speech rules-- say, on
their web pages--
to make sure that the math they
write, or they put on the
web, is pronounced
in the right way.
And for instance, I personally,
as a university
lecturer, university professor,
could imagine that
I'll put some of my lecture
notes on the web.
And as I know exactly how things
have to be pronounced,
I also put speech rules there
so my students with visual
impairments can actually go
there, and listen to the math
in the correct way, in exactly
the way I would
speak it in my lecture.
Right.
And with this, I'll end my part
of the presentation and
pass back to David, who's going
to conclude with some
more details on ChromeVox
and the project.
DAVID TSENG: All right, thank
you so much, Volker.
I wanted to conclude by
thanking everyone for
watching, and sticking with us
through all of our demos.
You can find a little bit more
information about ChromeVox on
chromevox.com.
And we are an open
source project.
So you can actually even take
a peek at all of our code,
including all of the things
that make math possible.
We'd be happy to take any
feedback that you have.
You can also visit us, in
general, for accessibility, at
Google, at the address
google.com/accessibility.
Thanks again for watching.
And we hope to receive any
feedback that you have.
Thanks.